it came up on my timeline obviously you
guys have all seen it whatever fight of
the week it's so funny we were talking
about I'm brilliant but like
yeah it's interesting like I wasn't
engaged by it at all initially I didn't
understand really what was going on yeah
so I kind of like scrolled past it and
it kept popping up and then once I got
into like the origin story of it yeah
it's pretty awesome it's the greatest
thing dude you need some character
development for sure yeah
fine I'm like who gives a [__] like I
like the Bobby shmur to throw in the Hat
thing that was kind of cool but then
like when I saw the guy jump into the
water to swim to the fight crazy yeah I
mean
unbelievable and then get out of the
water and start piecing what's up like
he was [__] people up this guy yeah
yeah yeah it was just really okay I
don't know what are you guys thoughts on
it what is the first thing honestly we
have to just admit that black people are
the funniest race
no matter what's happening if you're on
black Twitter even if it's to them
against them whatever they're gonna have
so much [__] fun with it bro have you
seen the nickname for this swimmer no
what is it they some of them are Aquaman
yeah Michael P Phelps
scuba Gooding Jr
my black Twitter was having a [__]
feel them our Homie real battle told me
last night he said I started watching I
just like clocked in around like
midnight just to see I had to be up at
like 8 A.M for work and then I kept
looking at means until five in the
morning I could not stop I could not
stop laughing at what they were saying
this they called the fight uh one of the
terms is Lift Every arm and swing
there's another one I have a couple
written down but it was so [__]
fading in the water oh yeah the fade in
the water fade in the water yeah yeah
yeah just pay it in the water pretty
fire dude I mean just so funny dude this
girl on Twitter said uh we gotta we
gotta call it uh Malcolm X now because
you know black Twitter yeah yeah yeah
yeah
uh but not even on black Twitter only
like just in person the fact that they
all start singing Ludacris's Move [__]
Oh my god dude we're together
no build up to the fight is these these
white dudes they just wouldn't move
right they're stupid this big boat
needed to dock there and then these
white dudes just wouldn't dock their
boat wouldn't move there they wouldn't
move their boat to that Boca dot yeah
and then the security guard is trying to
get them to move and they're just like
being [__] about it so the people on
the boat started singing move [__] get
out the way to get them to move and then
they still refuse to move and that's
when it escalates into the fight the
security guard is trying to do his
[__] job and one dude just like we
call mushism like big faces them she
loves them and then that's when the
black dude throws his hat and this is a
bad signal if you see a half line in
there
this was cool because he's fighting the
one dude and nobody's doing anything and
then you can see like footsteps all of a
sudden the white dude's friends jump in
and as soon as that happens you're gonna
see black feet running to the scene of
what's Happening like they're not gonna
let him get pieced up and jumped yeah
that's like the whole thing started this
is the [__] greatest moment of the
unity yeah now I would say this guy is
kind of a hero this first dude that
jumps in this one black dude tries to
stop it basically the whole thing ends
for a little bit he jumps in and he's
like all right we gotta stop this thing
he protects everyone everyone stops and
then all the black dudes are like wait
you just got jumped then that's when it
starts going crazy and they all get
their get back oh uh I want to find this
picture of this this guy but then block
a man comes up but he starts swimming up
to the dock
I don't know if you watched uh like I
love the picture with it looks like end
game and all the black people are coming
out
like that's [__] unbelievable bro I
don't know if you'll get this one you
ever watch Good Times no at the end of
good times and you might have just seen
this painting in general they always
play this like they show this historic
black painting of like black people
dancing playing jazz they got this same
painting I'll send this to you miles so
you can put on the screen but it's just
the same black people but they're
holding metal chairs bro the chair
[__] unbelievable man yeah I think
Alex you pointed it out that when the
guy hits the girl in the head of the
chair yeah
that was like their Hiroshima moment you
know what I mean it's like you might
have gone too far but it was over it did
end the whole thing and that was the
Final Smash and this white dude with a
sandal in his shorts he's the one that's
starting the whole thing he started the
fight and then after it yesterday
comes around he gets on the lady in the
red so yeah that just I thought it was
respectful that the girls are running
for the girls guys were going for you
guys yeah that was kind of new who to
team up with it was very respectful yeah
until that check came out then it got a
little crazy this is when the black
people really started once the boat the
big boat docked that's when the black
girl started coming off the boat
two black girls just piecing up this
white girl and then they just throw her
in the [__] water yeah there's one
white dude who's getting his ass kicked
and then he just dives into the water to
escape the ass kicking the whole thing
dude I want to watch the whole thing
it's incredible people on the black
dudes initially jump in they're like the
white dudes are on the boat and they
want to fight him but they are too
scared of the water to get on the boat
so they're just like like kick in the
air and talking to [__] you know what I
mean it's so funny the Supreme fighters
of water and sea of both left like it
really was like the perfect army versus
Navy battle literally it's like Avatar
everyone's own element kind of coming at
it all right guys we're gonna take a
break real quick because I gotta tell
you about extra this is I don't care
what wallet you have you need one of
these if you don't have a wallet and
you're looking you get yourself an extra
if you have some [__] designer
product Christian Dior whatever wallet
you still need one of these and I'm
going to tell you all the reasons why
first of all quick card access take a
look at that ba there you go all your
cards pull out whatever one you need
that's just convenient second it don't
take up much space you put it in your
side pocket and you're living third and
this is the most important thing it has
two key tracker features first of all
that means it is trackable worldwide if
you lose your wallet or somebody steals
it you could just call that [__] up it
works on voice activation with Siri
Alexa Google home all that [__] and most
importantly again this is what I'm
telling you even if you've got a nice
wallet you need one of these this has
RFID protection which means if you're
traveling if you're a tourist and in one
of these cities we're afraid you're
going to get pickpocketed or scammed or
people are just going to skim your
information like that Boop like that
this protects you against debt so no
matter what wallet you have get yourself
an extra keep yourself safe it is
convenient it is the best wallet you can
get and you can get a discount because
we're flagrant and we always hook you up
go to
shop.exter.com
flagrant and get 25 off site-wide with
the code flagrant again that is shop dot
e k s t e r.com slash flagrant get 25
off and now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon clip if you want to
watch the full episode come hang out
with the boys you can do that at
patreon.com flagrant or
patreon.com2 come join the [__] Army
it's the best armor to be a part of do
we know it's happened have there been
arrests like what yeah a bunch of people
got arrested the kid that swam across
got a GoFundMe and people started giving
them like tons of money well they shut
the gulf on me down it makes much money
yeah my fire dude
Michael B Phelps dude so [__] good
his boots got [__] up
Michael B Phelps is hilarious yeah it's
amazing and there's also it doesn't ever
escalate there's no guns I I didn't hear
that there was any like racial slurs
there's no weapons you just seemed like
a good old-fashioned Shaw the chair was
awesome wait what'd you say the chair
was a weapon oh yeah but that's that's
Hell in a Cell you know I mean like
that's a real weapons wouldn't you
rather get hit by a chair that a fist uh
probably uh yeah I 100 that's a plastic
chair a plastic chair they don't punch
each other in the face in wrestling but
they hit each other with chairs and
wrestling for a reason
yeah but they still like they pull back
on it it's not like a real hit you think
or you could take a chair yeah the
chairs
I want to agree with you but here's the
thing when you're coming down if you're
making it look real the momentum's so
crazy you can't really pull back without
it looking super obvious so they
probably hit him in a way that it
doesn't hurt to your point this [__]
got his Square in the floor
I would have been so happy if the chair
went through her head and then she wore
like a necklace that would have made me
so happy
she was just standing there and I don't
even know that these white dudes were
racist I think they were just drunk
rednecks but it's so [__] fun still
yeah that's awesome yeah I mean this was
fantastic dude watching this bullies get
their asses kicked I mean unbelievable
take even the race Dynamics out of it
you're seeing this bully just beat up
this blue Dynamic just makes it easier
to follow yeah exactly like you know the
song like football jerseys
so it's like you know who to fight with
yeah cause you're just looking for the
black dudes yeah and you know who to hit
yeah because you're just either looking
for the whites or the black dudes and
then as the consumer of the delicious
content
just you know who's winning who's losing
yeah it's really great I've seen this
this video to The Nook If You Buck song
in the background
amazing I mean it's unbelievable more
than half the people have no idea why
they're fighting though oh yeah they
just see the fight going on it's like ah
they've been drunk on a boat all day and
all of a sudden a fight happens I mean
the security guard could not be happier
yeah mushed that like that was the best
part the best thing that could have
happened is that the guy mushed him and
he was like finally yeah he wanted to
fight so bad like you could just see it
he kept on trying to do something and he
wouldn't be throwing the first punch and
now he's completely Vindicated yeah once
he's attacked he's good to go this is
the best case scenario that's [__]
great and that's another hat that never
came down bro yeah exactly
two of them orbiting right now yeah
there's angles
swam 16 years old swims across the water
and then just starts beating up throwing
ass men he's suplexing somebody grabs a
guy and just [__] oh that's right
backwards suplex is a guy I mean he's a
beast dude he's like WWE it's awesome
this kid should be if Vince McMahon
knows what he's doing he brings his kid
immediately to SummerSlam or whatever
the next big [__] event is just
started they do like a water portion or
some [__] like if you have the ring in a
moat or something you got a moat around
it you will watch wrestling remember
when like all the guys would start
fighting and it's like fake but it's
still [__] this is real that Royal
Rumble yeah yeah like you know one guy's
getting jumped and then all of a sudden
his other people run out of the tunnel
and start helping them not even Royal
Rumble that just happened this is that
but real yeah yeah fire dude I bet no in
the South they will be on pontoon boats
the next weekend both families all the
people that were in this fight and
they'll just kind of wave at each other
yeah 100 because they're all like drunk
and they probably would call each other
I'm sorry did I send you the video of
the white kid no the white kid I thought
look all [__] up and he goes well I
guess that old black guy could fight
turns out 65 year old man can throw a
punch yeah stuff like that but we
watched him yeah
he might have been you know coming back
from a surgery uh use the moment I don't
know if it was the guy because the guy
in there looked a lot older that looked
like a little kid I thought there was
some kids in there too there were some
younger people but if you're probably
right but there were some younger people
in there yeah I mean it's the best
moment on Twitter this year and it's not
even close and I'm struggling to think
of a funnier too if you're if you're
like an engineer not even an engineer
you're like some executive over at
Twitter and you're like our usage
absolutely hits the moon when things
like this happen are you like deviously
trying to curate these events trying to
stoke this yeah like any time there is
there's a public fight Twitter is
incredible do you have to give the
creators something to bounce off of
I don't know I do not start a race ride
somewhere race rights are great for
Twitter they are [__] amazing for
Twitter it's great for Ratings period
that's the most [__] does just put us
against each other and this is just
actually seeing the fight and now we
don't even have to the the good guys the
one so we just get to have fun and make
jokes yeah Pro Aqua Maine
amazing unbelievable Crocs needs to come
out and be like yo those are some
bootlegates
blasted through yeah that company's
gonna take a hurt yeah I mean I get it
like were you raised with this idea to
never wore sandals yeah wait why for
fighting purposes yeah I felt like that
if I was walking on the street with a
woman
this is so funny because I was talking
to this dude unique and he was like yeah
you can't wear sandals you gay and I was
like what do you mean if you go to the
beach he's like nope can't wear sandals
at the beach either Gotta Wear booties
nah gayer he was like nope no sandals
allowed what if a car a fight a gang
member someone runs up on you you gotta
be able to move yeah
you can't have no you can never wear the
song you have no [__] uh what's it
called like oh attraction if you're on a
boat or if you're at a beach or
something like that the sandals rules
don't apply he says also if you're
hooping you can pull up in slides
that's true so there are circumstances
but just like you're walking around on
your everyday Saturday to go get a
coffee and you got your girl you got
sandals now you got to get [__] up
just to teach you a lesson like you
thought it was sweet out here that's New
York have you ran up on someone just
says sandals cash I just slapped the
dude in sandals with his family say what
his family was there no not his family
he was him and his girl and I slapped
him right now and I took a white chair
and I broke it over myself
I am a Trailblazer bro damn dude but
hell yeah but yeah this is kind of proof
right I feel like the people that lost
were not wearing Jordans and then the
people that one did have a lot of Jordan
the 16 year old took off his shoes
16 year old went Barefoot because they
were wet as [__] so he took the shoes
off oh yeah it would have been funny if
he took them all before he jumped in the
morning he's like
come on it's fine yeah yeah no I think
this should be a commercial for Jordan's
really yeah it's like yeah black dudes
just don't wear sandals to the boat and
they won
this really is a footwear battle at the
end of the day if you want to watch the
full episode come hang out with the boys
you can do that at patreon.com flagrant
or
patreon.com2 come join the [__] Army
it's the best armor to be a part of